Using tools,
so islands to go.
Apparently they use tools like to get,
um,
like they'll stick sticks
into a ant hills to Cannes,
but they're also use rocks to break
things open or do you want to be,
I would imagine Abe's would follow suit.
I think they've,
what they're saying is they're saying
officially that they've entered into the
stone age. Oh boy. So
like if we are watching,
if you saw a human evolve from being a,
a person that you know what we,
whatever the fuck we used to look like
when they first figured out fish hooks
teaching to today, you know, there's
many, many generations of change and all,
all sorts of different shit that we
learned that we are watching literally the
birth of that separation between like
the regular chimps that are just chilling
in the forest to the chimps that are
starting to figure out tools and weapons.
Like the first day we see a chimp
make a fucking spear like a sphere,
sharpen it up and stab another chimp
death. Yeah. Yeah. Same
chimps are becoming woke.
Is that what's happening? Like they're
becoming an enlightened and smarter.
I don't think just chimps. There was
one with an orangutan. It was amazing.
I'm around town was spearfishing. Oh
No, dude, you gotta see it. It's crazy.
It's really crazy.
It's a beautiful photo of me walking down
the highway with like a briefcase soon.
I don't think it's going to be,
they're freaky man. That freaks me out.
But it is a,
so we're witnessing evolution.
They're learning things. And this one,
I think the issue was that this, uh,
orangutan had watched fishermen do this,
so he had apparently
watched some fishermen like
standing on a ledge and stab
fish. So he decided to try
to figure it out himself.
That makes sense. I mean, that's how all
creatures essentially, I mean, puppies,
kittens, they all learn. It's
just to be, it's to a limit.
They don't get past that sort of being
able to use tools to get the picture.
That's a wild,
it was bringing a video too,
so I thought there might've had video
of it, but, um, my dog opened his dog,
his dog food container when I was
gone. Damn. A twist. A twist. Yes,
we did it.
I got to get a camera,
but I came home and that top was
twisted off in his belly was like
the rang Tang spear phishing.
I mean, that's crazy.
If you saw that in a movie, you would
say, that is fake. That is so easy.
That looks like a still from jungle book.
It's amazing.
It's an amazing photo photo framed.
Jimmy,
get a copy of that photo and
let's do that. That's really cool.
That fucker framed.
I talk about this picture all the time.
It's so wild. So fascinating. It
really looks like the jungle book.